so getting into the show one of my
favorite parts of the wild is how it's
introduced me to so many incredible
rising stars that i did not know before
and you've worked with many of them and
shared many scenes with them so even
with all of your experience can you give
us an example of what when one of the
younger co-stars i guess surprised you
whether it was you know by using a
technique that you had never seen before
or maybe adding something to a scene
that wasn't on the page that you know
really shook something up well i think
kind of most young actors really are
going on instincts and less on technique
and that's probably what makes them so
powerful to be honest
they just really are living breathing
you know i certainly don't
you know
believe it's a method thing but you just
the just the the
i was constantly astonished by their
ability
to
um
just to live
these gamut of emotions and just let
them come out in such kind of
raw ways you know and um
i think they all realized um i mean the
boys were
fabulous in season two but i think the
girls
you know as a young actress
you get a lot of [ __ ] you get a lot of
rubbish
you know you see a lot of
representations and scripts you read
particularly on television
um and
uh that just are
very male gaze and very reductive and
not really that honoring of female
experience or sexualizing in a way that
does not reflect our lived experience
um and i think these young women really
knew that this was a very very rare
opportunity to
to
explore and and represent a full
diversity of um
a female experience and they just went
for it they just all [ __ ] went for it
um so i was just constantly astonished
and
and i think the other thing that will
always just blew me away
is you know sarah would write these very
intricate like monologues like
monologues that
i you know some of them were
more dense and nuanced and
more of a roller coaster ride than
anything i've ever been given you know
as a
as a young actress particularly and just
their facility to to handle the language
because sarah's language is very
specific it's so specific
um it's probably the only writing i've
ever had where i really really
insist upon being word perfect myself
because i know her choice of word is
subconscious
so the girls would be handling these
very
gymnastic
gymnastic
speeches with full kind of emotion
coming through
um
and that just yet always blew me away so
with uh what you said about working with
sarah's material in mind are there any
particular beats for gretchen whether
it's season one or season two where
you were so focused on what she created
and like you really had to talk it
through to fully understand and to fully
understand the motivation behind
gretchen's choices
you know i guess i was always wanting to
be very specific because gretchen
herself is very specific and
and honestly it's like it's really rare
in
in one's career that if you go to the
showrunner or the writer and you know
ask why particular word's been used or
why would she
say something in this way the answer was
always there there was
and and maybe like two times over the
entire season of those questions
or maybe one time sarah sarah would say
oh yeah actually cut that line i never
really liked it
because if she couldn't answer it she
knew
i had named the things oh in the room
we're tossing back and forth and you're
right let's just get rid of it
but there was always an answer like
amy and sarah just
show their character development and
thinking behind every single character's
journey was so
honored um
that that's you know it's just such a
it's such a gift for an actor because
it's otherwise you're like swimming
you're swimming like with the tide not
against the tide because the writing is
taking you the the writing is the tide
and the writing kind of takes you there
um
i think the you know one
one thing i used to say to them is like
all right how crazy am i in this scene
goes pretty crazy i'm like should i go
like okay i'll put that first take down
i'm gonna go full clown right
and they always gave me permission to
kind of push and sometimes it was so
stupid i would go so extreme
and everyone would laugh and you know
sarah would be like maybe it's a little
more grounded in reality
but they would kind of let us find where
that gretchen thing
that um
but yeah sometimes i got a few laughs
behind camera because i she's just so
unhinged i'd come back and then just be
like laughing
i was like should i do a little less and
they're like
a little less you got to twist the
limits with a character like that i get
it yeah i i think so i think so but
sometimes i'd be so afraid that i was in
my own show because the you know the
kids are so earnest with their emotional
journeys
um and they just full throttle like
embrace an emotional realism right
they're fully emotionally real
um
and correction is like such a construct
i'm like am i in the same show are you
sure i can assure you it feels like you
are in the same show you are excellent
in it yet again
i got a million more questions that
hopefully we'll get to in the future but
congratulations
hopefully there's another opportunity
thanks kerry i'll never say no to them